[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
und guten abend hinein zu einem kurzen
heute journal das sich erst mal mit der
großen frage beschäftigt kommt ab morgen
wieder gas aus russland
die antwort lautet aktuell offenbar ja
aber sie merken schon an der
formulierung das ist alles andere als
sicher und wenn russland wieder liefert
bleibt unklar erstens wie viel und
zweitens wie lange am ende ist es eine
hochpolitische entscheidung die wird die
mir putin treffen wird auch wenn
offiziell allerlei technische
hindernisse genannt werden die eu warnt
jedenfalls russland erpresst uns setzt
energie als waffe ein um da besser
vorbereitet zu sein kommt heute aus
brüssel ein notfallplan mit spaß von
gunnar krüger
heißer dampf und verzichtbar für die
chemische industrie
dieses kraftwerk in höchst bei frankfurt
produziert ihn bald wieder mit heizöl
statt mit dem zunehmend knappen erdgas
den brennstoff zu wechseln ist eine
empfehlung der eu-kommission gezielte
gas sperren sind eine andere
lieferketten für unverzichtbare produkte
sollen möglichst lange weiterlaufen
schwierig in höchst chemie und pharma
etwa kann man nicht trennen trotzdem
viele gute ansätze und ideen nicht alle
sind geeignet aber etliche sind durchaus
geeignet und sollten schnell umgesetzt
werden den zeitdruck gibt die eu heute
weiter die mitgliedstaaten sollen den
verbrauch um 15 prozent senken zunächst
freiwillig motto ist das motto ist je
schneller wir handeln je mehr wir sparen
desto sicherer sind wir das ziel ist
noch kein zwang der kommission fehlt die
kompetenz die ganz entscheidende frage
wenn es jetzt zu einer gas mangel lager
auf europäischer ebene kommt wie denn
jetzt das gas verteilt wird wer dann
noch welches bekommt das machte die
kommission jetzt uns beantworten dazu
müsste eine mehrheit der
mitgliedsstaaten der kommission mehr
macht geben oder die frage selbst regeln
doch bilateraler abkommen zum
gasaustausch gibt es bislang nur sechs
dieses vakuum nutzt putin der gestern
erst versichert
der hat seine verpflichtungen bislang
erfüllt erfüllt sie jetzt und wird sie
immer erfüllt und dem selben atemzug
sagt das sei nicht möglich wegen
eu-sanktionen in diesem spiel braucht
nicht nur die deutsche wirtschaft eine
eu die entscheidet ein verteilungskampf
ums gas wäre zu putins vorteil
ja deswegen noch mal nachgefragt in
berlin und aller guten abend da ist
jetzt absehbar bereits ein monatelanges
zitterspiel das präsident putin mit uns
vorhat wie will denn die bundesregierung
damit umgehen ja am liebsten würde sie
putin diesen erpressungs hebel ganz aus
der hand nehmen indem sie deutschland
vollkommen unabhängig macht von
russischer energie und daran arbeitet
sie auch schon hat heute dazu einen
sogenannten fortschrittsbericht
vorgelegt das ist der dritte in einer
reihe seit sie angefangen hat die
energiepolitik umzustellen und da zeigt
sich allerdings auch schon es ist
mühselig bei öl und kohle kommt man wohl
voran allerdings bleibt das große
problem gas da schreibt also die
bundesregierung heute selbst wenn alles
klappt und wenn alle alle möglichkeiten
genutzt werden und neue quellen
erschlossen werden um gas aus anderen
ländern zu bekommen und wenn dann
wirtschaft und verbraucher auch noch
sparen wird man bis zum jahresende immer
noch 30 prozent russisches gas brauchen
um energiesicherheit herzustellen und
gänzlich unabhängig wird man nach diesem
plan erst im sommer 20 24 sein das heißt
also auf absehbare zeit erst einmal
nerven behalten wenn putin wieder am
gashebel dreht und weiter versuchen
unabhängig zu werden ein controller
vielen dank und was der chef der
bundesnetzagentur zu all dem sagt
nachher im heute-journal update
wie der gluthitze heute in deutschland
und nicht nur bei uns in vielen teilen
von süd europa zwingen waldbrände die
menschen zur flucht ein besonderes
beispiel für den ernst der lage ist
griechenland dort war es gar nicht
einmal übermäßig heiß kein vergleich mit
den temperaturen aktuell bei uns und
dennoch sorgt die lange schon anhaltende
trockenheit dort für eine gefährliche
lage insbesondere in den vororten von
athen
felix johanns
es ist ein verzweifelter kampf aus der
luft und am boden
und längst nicht überall wird dieser
kampf gewonnen
es ist eines der schlimmsten feuer das
ich je erlebt habe es ist ein großes
gebiet mit steilen hängen häusern direkt
im wald brennbarem material und leider
kommen dazu noch die starken winde
wir kämpfen seit gestern abend wir haben
das haus in letzter minute gerettet aber
das feuerwehrauto hatte irgendwann kein
wasser mehr und das feuer brennt immer
wieder neu am abend gibt die feuerwehr
erstmal entwarnung der brand bei athen
sei größtenteils unter kontrolle doch es
ist nur ein brand von 117 in ganz
griechenland
sie sind für ganz frankreich helden
ruhepause für feuerwehrmänner die
südlich von bordeaux gegen zwei
großbrände kämpfen
am anfang sind wir frisch nach zwei
tagen aber wirst du müde und
unaufmerksam und dann müssen wir
vorsichtig sein man hat ein viel höheres
unfallrisiko
riesige brandschneisen sollen den
flammen jetzt die angriffsfläche nehmen
momentan sind die behörden vorsichtig
optimistisch dass dieser plan aufgeht
dem motto es nihil nisi bene der
lateinische spruch hat nicht umsonst
seine gültigkeit und seinen wert bereits
seit antiken zeiten über tote sollte man
nur gutes sagen
das heißt für dieter wedel er war ein
großmeister des fernsehfilms er hat
millionen menschen vor dem bildschirm
gebannt unterhalten grimme-preise
bundesverdienstkreuz der regisseur ist
im alter von 82 jahren gestorben
das war bereits letzte woche wurde aber
erst heute bekannt und zwar durch eine
mitteilung des landgerichts münchen 1
und damit sind wir bei dem was die
letzten jahre seines lebens überschattet
hat und jetzt juristisch nicht mehr
geklärt werden kann der schwere vorwurf
der vergewaltigung annegret oster
fordernd und herausfordernd war er ein
perfektionist der seinen akteuren nicht
leicht machte theater intendant und star
regisseur eigentlich wollte dieter will
schauspieler werden wenn dann
vorsprechen waren war jemand der
schlechteste und dann hat mir ein
schauspiellehrer gesagt sie sind kein
system keine schauspielerin regisseur
einen untrüglichen sinn für themen die
die menschen interessieren den hatte
dieter wedel wie kaum ein anderer der
große bellheim fesselte in den 90ern ein
millionenpublikum
auch der schattenmann mit mario adorf
als mafiaboss ein riesenerfolg für mich
ist so ein film wie eine große
elektrische eisenbahn und ich darf alles
bestimmen und
versuche auch natürlich die zügel und
die kontrolle in der hand samen und ich
darf mir eine geschichte ausdenken
wedels eigene erfolgsgeschichte dagegen
endete jäh
2018 im zuge der mito debatte
beschuldigten ihn mehrere
schauspielerinnen öffentlich der
sexuellen gewalt was alle fälle waren
jedoch bereits verjährt wedel selbst
bestritt die vorwürfe bis zuletzt
die staatsanwaltschaft erhob im
vergangenen jahr allerdings anklage
wegen vergewaltigung gegen wedel ob sie
zugelassen wird oder nicht wollte das
landgericht münchen heute bekanntgeben
stattdessen verkündete es nun die
beendigung des strafverfahrens
damit nimmt wedel die wahrheit mit ins
grab
weitere nachrichten in der übersicht
hast du jetzt
in italien spitzt sich die krise um die
regierung von ministerpräsident nadschi
wieder zu zwar gewann er am abend eine
entscheidende vertrauensabstimmung im
senat jedoch fehlte ihm die
unterstützung von drei wichtigen
regierungsparteien somit wird in rom
nicht ausgeschlossen dass der 74 jährige
erneut seinen rücktritt anbietet der
russische außenminister lavrov hat mit
einer ausweitung des militäreinsatzes in
der ukraine gedroht und zugleich
friedensverhandlungen abgelehnt die
angriffe konzentrieren sich aktuell auf
den süden und osten der ukraine
unterdessen gelang es der ukrainischen
armee eine für die russischen truppen
wichtige brücke schwer zu treffen
nach 18 jahren soll hartz4 abgeschafft
und durch ein bürgergeld ersetzt werden
laut arbeitsminister heil sind zwei
jahre karenzzeit geplant für die
bewertung von wohnung und vermögen über
die arbeitsvermittlung hinaus soll es
mehr anreize zur weiterbildung geben und
in einer sechsmonatigen vertrauens zeit
keine leistungskürzungen die siebzehnte
etappe der tour de france hat der
slowenische radprofi pokal gewonnen nach
130 kilometern siegte der
titelverteidiger vor dem dänen weniger
er weiter im gelben trikot fährt simon
geschke aus berlin sicherte sich den
neunten tag in folge das bergtrikot
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
ohne gewähr 23
36 42 43 49 superzahl 2 mehr auf lotto
zdf de und im zdf text und das wetter
bringt etwas weniger hitze und dafür
gewitter morgen im norden regen mit
blitz und donner sowie im osten und am
alpenrand sonst viel sonne 21 bis 32
grad am samstag einige schauer und
gewitter meist aber trocken mit viel
sonne im süden heiß über 30 grad und
damit sagen wir danke für heute gerne
bis morgen und wünschen viel spaß beim
fußball in allen belangen im sommer
abend
[Musik]